and when welcome to this video playing
Sunkist what am i doing yeah let's start
with that and then decide g3 is an
interesting move actually I think the
stead c5 is a good good way to play
against it but it's some about the only
real argument against this move water
okay so here quite happy that looks like
a soul of green felt reversed where he
did not manage to take on c6 not the end
of the world but I think he quite
comfortable for for black yeah I was
thinking about it etc said a good move I
mean the the test must be the capture
okay some interesting
hmm hey I got an acquaintance good good
amount of passe not just like see I mean
they all hang five hangs indirectly that
same
it's not so easy even to keep your 5
covered conveniently not happy with this
Bishop a six maybe Bishop is six bishop
chicks girl sorry Knight takes e5 I
don't know that looks extremely passive
I don't like to play the move but
it's hard to do how to play without this
without f6 I needed to get to a position
where I can actually get get the knight
to move on to seven
made a 5 as 95 is in on the cards ugly
very ugly
yeah look on the seventh rock c7 would
be a problem okay he wants to go Bishop
f5 I guess
yeah I was thinking King a six but then
he can't even go okay form you should be
eight it's also not good
hmm
I am playing this this game like a
complete idiot
somehow it looks completely terrible oh
my goodness absolutely atrocious yeah
and the problem is I don't have root g8
I don't have root d8 I mean if I would
be like somehow getting on that open
fire
I mean maybe I am crap sorry
maybe there's the odd activity may not
unbelievable game
yeah probably decayed c4 was crap really
I mean I can pledge that but this should
be six and I'm fine of course but I
wanted to I know somehow punish him for
what exactly I don't know
[Music]
I came
I just totally lost year and nothing
nothing more nothing less
threatening III but like h6 just wins
and probably some other moves also when
but maybe I should have gone to see the
reaction
yah-hoo Kim
you know it's always frustrating it it
doesn't even play it well but it's just
so lost its you that you can do whatever
[Music]
your gauge six was a tad easier but
No blah yeah that was a really bad
decision to take I mean and maybe not
objectively but I mean I can just for
simplicity's sake I can just do this and
I'm fine of course and this is just like
totally nothing for white but yeah I
really didn't see how problematic this
would become at least you have to be
extremely precise okay when the engine
wants to put the King on to e6 which is
a cool way to do it ya hear this this is
now not really this is bad you know what
I'm doing after 97 that's just way too
passive him if I thought I could
organize this somehow but it really
thought it really was bad but should be
690 to f6
yeah well the computer actually thinks
I'm okay we should before and then just
take the two we are of course then I'm
getting rid of this idiotic Bishop
finally yeah that is a lot better
also here yeah dad that's a lot better
yeah here I mean of course I mean I did
not like to take on c4 I mean taking me
but I didn't really see I felt this is a
problem maybe this was the problem in my
reasoning that this is not a problem
take knight c6 52 I was a bit scared him
that then I got some issues with the
king
hmm now this is fine and even this is
fine yeah this is the real issue I mean
I was totally I was I knew that I would
get into into an uncomfortable situation
after the capture but I didn't really
see what to do against 985 was my
problem but it does not seem to be an
issue at all but even just developing
it's okay yeah but not great Roxy to
Dublin yeah I should play Bishop before
yeah that that was a lot stronger in
this position sucks it really sucks we
should see three is a strong move I mean
this already looks fairly awful but
Bishop c3 is strong one one you I had
one against her
Jim this is all very strong I felt he
was struggling slightly at the ending is
she so lost
yes it's basically that doesn't matter
what you do I mean you can make the odd
your neck in inaccurate move and it
doesn't really hurt him okay guys thanks
for watching